you have to ask the question are black
people normally playing petty criminals
are women always the love interest or
talking about men are gay people always
stereotyped are disabled people at the
scene at all let's just get more
professional about this whole area our
economy and said before depends on it my
agent and I would get scripts and we
were always asked to read the black male
character now a white character or white
males always called a Caucasian a man of
a twinkle in his eyes now my eyes may be
dark but they definitely twinkle I saw
the glass ceiling I knew there wasn't
another mat enough imagination not yet
for the industry to be seeing me as a
lead
what a girl yeah